après je voulais être épouvantail je
disais partout que je voulais être
épouvantail j'étais persuadé d'avoir un
métier d'avenir là je trouvais ça fout
près c'est vrai en plus ce serait mon
frère je trouve un système pour me
dégourdir les bras mais sinon j'étais
vraiment sûr que c'est un métier après
j'ai voulu être
documentaliste au cdi je trouvais que
les cdi c'était merveilleux
bon alors qu'en fait il passe son temps
à dire juste bien près j'ai voulu être
acteur très vite pas un humoriste
d'abord et puis après acteurs
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui c'est l'anniversaire papier
cousy alors c'est 50 hippique
à la cca encore s'appelle viala mais
sauf que suivre et catella fallait pas
ce qu'elle a mangé oui
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je vais venir torturé à à
emma et fabien le couple
d'altermondialistes euros dans scènes de
ménages
dupont plein milieu de la nuit pendant
un grand un grand orage un éclair fait
sauter les plombs de la maison est
quelqu'un
frappe à la porte c'est catherine où
vous gougoux une sorte de morticia adams
qui vit seule sans mari juste avec un
majordome dans un manoir depuis les
années 80 seule sans la télévision sans
la radio et son internet
l'association c'était pour moi c'est une
des meilleures attaques de tous les
temps je pense qu'il faut ressortir à
l'époque de devant de bastennes tous à
la vente basten gullit riches gardent ça
c'est un trio qui envoyait mais là je
pense que nous on a fait un effort tu
avais refusé
beill
pavé le buteur cristiano et puis moi
j'étais un peu entre les deux ce qu'il
faut toujours la pièce qui font entre
les deux pour que tout marche en fait
avec ces deux joueurs là tu avais pas de
zone 9 en fait